um
on the light-hearted side um you know
typically we have a lot of hip-hop
people on the podcast
i know you're a hip-hop guy um
what are your like top three four or
five albums of all time sean king
oh man man i would have to
you know i i was a huge nipsy fan
and i keep nipsey's last album on it's
literally
maybe the only thing that i listen to
consistently
yeah so i just so i continue to to
listen to it sometimes
the only thing i do to mix it up is like
sometimes i'll put it on a shuffle
you know to mix the mix the order of it
up
um then i would have to go back man i
would have to go
i still listen to the stuff that i grew
up on you know i grew up on tupac i grew
up on biggie
uh i've tried to teach and share some of
that with my kids like the
uh the the edited versions but edited
old school hip-hop they didn't edit as
well it was like reverse words
what was going on anyway yeah yeah so
the edits aren't nearly as
clean man um
you know i i love the good kid mad city
from kendrick
and i still think that might be my
favorite kendrick album of all time
i mean you know what's crazy with that
with that album
everyone reveres that as like his
classic like his like illmatic if you
will
yeah in a way right if you go back and
listen to like to pimp a butterfly
yeah page so well with what's going on
in the world oh
absolutely no no it is so relevant for
for now
and then um man i would have to
i would have to go back man i have a
hilarious
uh story about some west coast rappers i
wish i have to come back on and tell you
this story
but uh i grew up listening to uh like
west coast rappers like sibo who was up
in
chibo sibo brother lynch all that yep
yeah all of that brother i listened to
brother lynch all of that stuff man
and uh i still go back and listen to
some of
some of my old i feel horrible when i
listen to it because
there's nothing ridiculous actually
brother lynch now i don't go back and
listen to brother lynch
when i was a kid and i heard brother
lynch i re i thought he was really out
here doing all that [ __ ] that was like i
was really freaked out
it was scary man it was on something
different like when i was a kid we were
told
that he was dead and that uh because he
was dead on the
on the album cover and uh we were all
like you know there was no social media
and so like rumors like that could
spread and last for a long time
and then his friend x-rated was in jail
like it was yeah that's so funny
no man i never would have taken you as a
brother lynch guy
no man we love this you know as kids now
when when brother lynch first came out i
was like 14 or 15 years old
and so man you know we were just bad ass
kids man so
and so all of that stuff you know i
loved e40 and the click
and and sibo and all of that i
uh i wrote a whole chapter about a story
i have with sibo
that that's not in this book but it'll
have to be in
maybe my next book i gotta share it with
you one day man